[Music]
all right guys i'm gonna show you
a video uh and so
just to give you a little background on
this video it takes place in ohio
this woman she was cooking
and as she was cooking she discovered
something very interesting
you guys will see what she discovered
you you can
make up your own mind was it a frog
inside of a turtle shell
here we go i thought she did what is
that
i thought she discovered life here we go
so i'm stirring like this
reminder i didn't notice this when i was
putting it don't mind my chicken i put
in here
um i didn't notice this when i
had did my turkey stuff my my
turkey tails but then i'm just stirring
you see this thing right here
what is that let me see that penis
this is supposed to be a turkey tail
what what that looks like kind of
familiar
what is that is that turkey penis do you
guys see that that looks like a dick
that looks like a human dick because my
eyes deceiving me
stiff nothing she left it in their pot
oh what that look like y'all tell me
if it looked like something very very
familiar i am just along the way
she at home though right
i am still going to
eat oh yeah don't waste food
i look good too i think they put the
wrong thing in them
i mean but is it a turkey neck have you
seen you've seen turkey necks i haven't
seen them
that long like they didn't like that
looks like it didn't chop
yeah you know when you pull out when you
make turkey it has yeah it's
a turkey neck is like part of the dick
you don't have the dick head that has a
[ __ ] on it doesn't it even has the
mushroom chip and everything
is it a turkey neck what is that well
i can't tell what it is is that a skin
snake
skin snake i'm just like she must have
like
have saw before she put it in she said
i'm still going to eat it
that means is it kind of looks like a
sausage because there's no hole where'd
a hole at well she did mention that
there is a hole
oh there a hole on the top does she
smell like a tip
what if it's somebody's dick like a
mobster killed somebody and chopped them
up
food from she cooked it how you not
noticing this she said she got a bunch
of
turkey necks maybe it's a turkey neck
bag maybe some girl i brought it up and
she's like wait aren't you the girl that
glitter vagina
and then was like why do you give me the
shirt like [ __ ] i'm gonna take it
yeah so this okay so she purchased this
at a supermarket called save a lot
see first off mom don't shop at a place
called salmon mama they saved a lot of
time
the body was chopped up that's why they
serving it to you
yeah was dick expensive or cheap i mean
personally i don't know how much did it
cost but probably dirt cheap
i never checked the price dick is
probably yeah it's way cheaper than
[ __ ] that's for sure
yeah yes because one is like you could
make a lot of money on and the other one
you're kind of just like you're in
trouble
no one wants it i mean could you imagine
buying can they buy
animal penises and vaginas i think so
if you go to a butcher shop you probably
can't i never thought an animal vagina
but i have seen
animal penises and balls right you
always the rocky mountain oysters
okay so interesting okay so
well here's the thing so she purchased
the package was supposed to be
smoked turkey tails oh tails
and but the receipt said that they were
they were smoked um
but but the label it was labeled as
smoked
pork tails even though they were seen
okay but that's not even the issue right
so it looked like a penis right
when she was cooking she was in the
middle of a facebook live video
oh and that's when she stopped stirring
the beans and she was like
wait this ain't right like what is this
so then that's when she ended up
investigating a little more and that's
when she saw that there is a hole at the
tip
like i mentioned right and so she became
convinced that it was a human penis
to the point where she first called the
health department but no one answered
because it's corona then she called the
cops and so
several officers went to her home i
think it was like 10 officers
hilarious yeah and they weren't
immediately convinced that it wasn't a
penis either
so 9-1-1 how may we help you
yo there's a i think there's a penis in
my in my
soup i need the police to come over
right away uh excuse me man please say
that again uh penis in my soup could you
imagine showing up like
so you got dick soup what do you want me
to do about this dixie
did you put it in there did you whose
dick is this is this is there's a cctv
of her buying like a knife to cut off a
penis
right yeah so then when the police went
they were examining it and they
so then that's when they threw it at
each other no you touch it no you touch
it can you imagine they're like
that's a pretty big penis to have been
soft
true that's a big dick for turkey
how big was it this song it's from a
previous video where we said it is how
we're going to be measuring penises from
now on
dick
anyway so then the police called the
medical examiner
and the coroner um yeah a lot of people
are any corpses missing a dick yeah
pretty much and so um that's that's what
she was saying during the live facebook
live
and then she said she's still gonna eat
it though well that's the thing like
she couldn't really because then the
cops took it all yeah she took it off my
lunch she's like i just made all this
damn dicks i spent
hours on that i told him dick was on the
menu
[Laughter]
she probably called the cops over like
you guys better come hungry
anybody had dick today i got it for you
the last the last step was like
like taste it does it taste funny does
it taste right
it's like i'm gonna surprise you all
right you're not gonna know what this is
so boiled penis still got dna all
yeah that's the reason okay that's the
reason why they took everything as
evidence did they find
out anything and then that's when okay
so they delivered the meat to the
medical
and to the medic medical examiner's
office
and that's where they they did some
tests
and they determined that even though it
was shaped like a penis it was just a
normal piece of pork
and in fact it was most likely a pigtail
because it was still a bone in it
oh yeah the picture was like [ __ ]
the curly thing but they're still boned
i just feel funny cartilage
like a big big ass look
good job for that pig yeah that pig was
a shower definitely like hey baby you
like this tail
oh i got that strong tail i thought they
had curly tails too
is that just the cartoons but i think
it's like bone like in the first
probably like in the beginning and then
the rest is cartilage
yeah yeah but she even said it though
because people were asking like what the
[ __ ] did it look like when you first put
it in and she said
she said listen yes i washed it off
before cooking but it didn't look like
that until i cooked it
oh okay it was it was flaccid going in
and it cooked into heart it just got
wrapped it was hot yeah hard when it was
hot that does look like a
dead look did she get to eat it no
that's good
but i mean oh that was gonna taste did
she taste the broth on the live
do you know she's all like could you
like she was like oh my god this is so
good and then she's fishing like hold on
y'all
hold on yo wait wait wait wait wait wait
that tastes familiar
i didn't put no i didn't put no penis in
this soup today who dipped their dick
dip their dick in my soup she did say
like that looks strangely familiar
i feel like strangely the closest thing
to the uh that kind of experience i had
is when
what um bart's dad was making soup
and he's all like yeah just come down
and grab a bowl any time he walks we
used to live together
anytime we have soup just go ahead and
grab it so he would always have some
soup and i'm like this is freaking
awesome
one day it went down and i'm like oh
there's a claw in here
and then a turtle head comes out and i
was like yeah that's a red ear slider
nope
and i put that closed it up dumped the
suit back in and i was like [ __ ] that
not eating anything he's cooking i
should have tried it but i don't know
it was just kind of you ever stopped
like my something about my dad's side
they love turtles
they just look they're wait wait they
just eat turtles on the regular
or is there turtle specific for eating
there's turtles specific for eating but
i went with one of the most
it was a radio slider dude so i guess
you could eat those
yeah the ones with the little red ears
no it was this big like it was huge
they get that big they eat it yeah i've
only ever seen them really tiny and cute
and little baby that's when you get them
as a baby so when i went with my dad to
china for the first time to visit some
some of that side of the family um my
dad was like oh we're gonna have a feast
tonight
just just make sure you don't like ruin
your appetite
and then one of the things that came out
was it just looked like steamed
uh soft shell turtles and then it's and
then there was it was just like a stack
of like four of them
on a plate and like i almost wanted to
throw up right then and there good thing
there's
tell you to eat before because it was
like i know but then everyone was just
looking at it like
like it was like thanksgiving crabs yeah
yeah like oh my god
we went to china we ate snake oh yeah we
had snake in china
it's [ __ ] weird too because we got to
like pick the snake
and then they killed it like which one
you want to eat now yeah and then it's
like you know how like
like seafood restaurants you pick the
fish like the crab
yeah we got to pick the snake i haven't
i had snake like in a sausage like a
water snake
i don't even know i don't know how was
it though that's good
it's bony you gotta work for the meat
you gotta like there's a lot of bones
like more than fish more than fish i
would think oh yeah that doesn't sound
pleasant
i the flavor i couldn't i was just like
were you two were you too hung up on the
fact that it was a snake i was i was i
really was but i'm like listen
i'm an experienced person i want to try
it okay i tried it was it good or not
i don't remember because i was just so
like holy [ __ ] i'm eating a snake
it was good though it was like a salt
pepper chicken wings salt pepper shrimp
like it was that that flavoring but with
game yeah i remember that the skin was
was oh they had the skin on it yeah have
you ever tried a turtle
never no i should have tried it i
shouldn't have judged it
but as soon as i saw it i just put the
soup back on
washed my dish and i just went to sleep
hungry my dad's probably still making it
mutant ninja turtles were just like no
donatello
what's the chicken or like some catfish
or something you know
and that turtle day maybe he was like
imma hook joe up with a turtle today
what's the wildest thing you've ate oh i
hate a lot of things that's why
but back then i didn't though so that
that was
not like jk party days you know i know
we were eating some crazy [ __ ] yeah i
mean we ate
we ate bubbles i think we've brought
bugs crickets and live octopus
uh we ate a lot of crazy [ __ ]
yeah yeah we tried kangaroo meat we've
tried whale
sashimi whale's good whale's really good
i see the people like post that like the
it's like a fat cap of blubber it's
actually really good
and they're like score and then they
just have it and they just eat it oh
dude i had uh
it was lean it was it was like uh just
like red meat
but it's purplish and then it's like
really soft filet mignon oh wow
beef mixed with iu tuna and just like if
you imagine that merged together
flavor of beef texture of tuna yeah so
it's like if
it's it's it breaks apart in your mouth
it's where did you try it
in japan oh yeah yeah we were in iceland
so we had a lot of weird stuff in
iceland
yeah i bet there like any like iceland
alaska any of those like
arctic or cold places i have a picture
of the whale sushi i had too it's pretty
good
i think it just depends on where you go
and where you travel because what's
in abundance is normally what people eat
yeah you know they don't have cows right
there's like there's no reason why any
of us should be eating whale in l.a
no like realistically why the hell would
there be a whale should she make
any turtles in l.a tradition though i'm
like you know i ain't trying to [ __ ] in
nobody's uh culture right now
but uh but if that's what you do because
it makes sense like how we look at crabs
like i had a giant
um crab claw the other day and like so
[ __ ] good but imagine if nobody ate
crab the way we ate crab they would be
looking at it like how we look at turtle
spiders
yeah yeah it's like a bug yeah it would
look at people
we would look at it like what the [ __ ]
is wrong with you like that's how
like us eating cow like indians like
they don't eat cow right
it's sacred yeah something yeah some
religion yeah yes
yeah they're like why the [ __ ] but
that's why it's like if we all sat here
and just thought about
different parts of the world and what
they eat you're like okay that makes
sense
but for us is it necessary and when
people start making [ __ ] possible i just
make fun of them for it
you